welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus docker on this
episode I talk with Robin Hansen who's
an economist at George Mason University
Robin has also spent decades researching
artificial intelligence and that is what
we talk about on this episode
we talk about which metrics might be
useful for measuring AI development
what we can know based on the current
data about how AI development is going
and at what speed and we talk about
whether AI development might be
dangerous in a way that would make it
rational for us to research AI safety
here's Robin Hansen Robin welcome to the
podcast hello guys
fantastic great tell us a bit about your
history working with on AI and debating
AI
so as a graduate student at the
University of Chicago
in 1982
or three
I
hung out in the physics Library
sometimes or and noticed some journals
that I would browse various journals and
I came across some articles in an
artificial intelligence Journal by
Douglas Leonard
where he was describing his famous
urisco system
uh an improvement of his previous am
math system
and I was very impressed
I thought that that was really cool
and
at a similar time there were many news
media articles about a revolution in
artificial intelligence happening at
that time and gushy sort of predictions
about how AI was about to just change
the economy radically and change jobs
and every all sorts of things
um
that was impressive I was impressionable
I was young and naive even and
impressionable and I heard that
basically out in Silicon Valley the
future was being created in AI research
at the time I was a graduate student in
philosophy of science who had then
switched into physics because I had to
get a physics Masters as part of my
PhD in philosophy of science and then I
decided to just get Masters in the two
subjects because I thought I had
answered the main question that I had
about philosophy of science
uh and so
you know in the physics library reading
about AI I saw this bright future and I
decided to go join it so I took the two
masters
and went out to Silicon Valley to join
the future of artificial intelligence
and roughly believing the gushy
forecasts in
in the media at the time
and
I also happened to read about
um stuff about hypertext publishing
stuff Ted Nelson had written I had been
in contact with some people I guess who
put me in touch with that and I also
thought that was very exciting
this was the precursor to the World Wide
Web but this was in the uh or you know
of early 1980s
and so I left University of Chicago in
1984 with two masters in philosophy of
science and physics and went off to
Silicon Valley in order to pursue these
two Futures that I had seen one was the
world wide web was coming famously only
started in 1994 but this was 1984 10
years ahead of time seeing the future
coming
and the artificial intelligence boom
that was existing at the time that I
wanted to join so this is the this AI
boom is this the boom where people were
trying to implement expert systems
certainly expert systems was a big part
of that yes yeah so this is before the
current paradigms of machine learning
long before so uh basically if we look
back now which I didn't at the time we
could say that roughly every 30 years
there's another big boom of interest and
concern about AI
and that previously in the early 1960s
there had been a similar boom and in the
1930s a similar boom and in the 19 2010s
a similar boom 30 years apart
and we are now sort of more toward the
tail end of that like 2010's boom or you
know after the Peak at least
but every 30 years for a while we've had
one of these bursts of interest and
concern about AI interest in the sense
there's investment in firms there's
people moving into Computer Sciences
students trying to get jobs uh art gushy
articles about progress concerned
articles about what could happen and go
wrong those have happened again 1930s
60s or you know
you know late 60s 80 90s 2010s you know
rough to that rate and we even had a
burst of concerns in the early 1800s
with the introduction of the Industrial
Revolution there was also a burst of
concern about
um where the where that automation
Revolution taken many people were
concerned right then and like the 1820s
that in fact machines would take all the
jobs away from humans even back then
so this is kind of like a cyclical view
of uh artificial intelligence uh boom
booms and busts and so this this view
predicts that we might be headed for
another bust period in which there isn't
that much interest isn't that much
funding not that many papers published
but this is
um I imagine that in the city not as
many yeah but of course even during the
the low points in this history there was
a lot of activity going on is it fair to
characterize you as a contrarian among
contrarians where
I imagine many people in your Social
Circles believe that AI will progress
quite rapidly uh in the in the coming 30
years say but you don't believe that so
are you are you uh yeah are you pushing
against contrarians so are you kind of
like a meta contrarian
so there's always the trouble of judging
attitudes and opinions on something
where
there's an asymmetry in how loud and
active people are
so consider say 9 11 truthers
right
now most people are not 911 truthers but
some people are and those that are it's
much closer to the center of their
identity
and they spend a lot more time on it and
they will give you a lot more detailed
arguments about it
and and see a 911 truther talking to a
skeptic and having a debate the truth or
will sound like they know a lot more
because they are studying this stuff and
this is their Center of their world and
the skeptic will just not be up on all
the details the truth or is but the
skepticals still say this just doesn't
all sound right and I can't be bothered
to get into this like sorry
I got other things to do
and that's just a consistent
pattern across a wide range of areas
where there's a small group of
passionate people on one side and a lot
of disinterested Skeptics on the other
side and that makes it hard for
Outsiders to judge who to believe in a
situation like that
because you know in any one case it does
look like the The Advocates no more
they've got the details they've got the
you know numbers and they can they can
quote people and they've got all the
specifics
and the Skeptics are distracted and not
that interested and they have some
arguments but they don't that careful or
thoughtful about them but there's just a
lot more of them and those other people
like getting other stuff done in the
world right and so who to believe
um you know that's just a hard situation
in general when we've got a small
fraction of passionate advocates in a
large world of somewhat in different
Skeptics
um I think we have more leverage to say
if we see that situation appearing over
and over again several times there's
this General situation of Skeptics you
know a small number of passionate
well-informed Skeptics and a large
number of indifferent you know people
doing other things
uh but sometimes we see that pattern
repeat a lot that is where we see a
small number of people passionately
advocating the same sort of thing over
and over again across time
and so I think we're in a better
position to draw some conclusions there
we can say well look all the previous
guys they were tended to be forecasting
stuff happening pretty soon and that
didn't happen so maybe we you know if
this happened five times before maybe we
can say well the probability that
they're going to be right this time is
maybe no more than one in five
let's look at all the previous times one
in five could still be big enough to be
worth paying attention to but you've got
a pattern right but this depends on the
quality of the the data that comes
before us so maybe in the past people
didn't have access to the same amount of
of the data and they they didn't maybe
they didn't think as clearly as we can
think now they didn't devote enough
resources to it that's just the general
situation for contrarians right so the
overall stats on contrarians is
contrarians are usually wrong right
just do the overall data set right and
so each set of criterions knows that
fact and they're each going to be trying
to tell you how they're different
because they think their odds of being
writer higher than this you know
Baseline rate right and so then that's
what you have to judge is okay which of
them are right so I think they do vary
in some ways for example you know for
example if we talked about UFOs I might
say well look if we look at say ghosts
and fairies like the best evidence for
ghosts and fairies just is not as good
as the best evidence for UFOs so I'm
gonna at least say UFOs look a little
better than ghosts and fairies doesn't
mean they're right it means I can make
some comparisons right
yeah and and hopefully I I or I think
you you believe that very fast AI
progress is even more plausible than uh
UFOs for example or at least more
plausible than ghost and ghosts and
fairies
sure sure I mean I've I've tried to do a
UFO analysis that is what's my prior
estimate that UFOs would be aliens and I
give it roughly 100 000 so
I'll give you more than one of the
Thousand for a fast view of AI progress
although I'm not sure how much more than
one of the thousand
but we'll get into that yeah exactly so
maybe before we get into that we should
think about the metrics we're using to
evaluate how fast AI is progressing well
let's ask why are we asking how fast AI
is progressing why is that the question
that's the question because uh well well
we were just uh debating what will
happen in the future and if we have some
some good measure of how AI has been
progressing in the fast in the past
maybe we can extrapolate from that into
what will happen in the future I think
that's the basic idea so let me try to
suggest a different framing
I'd say
there are a lot of Technologies we can
Envision happening in the future and a
lot of current Technologies could have
been envisioned in the past
and most technologies have some problems
associated with them things that can go
wrong
and at some point somebody should be
thinking about each of those things that
can go wrong so I've got no problem with
people worrying about things going wrong
and like trying to specialize that and
and work on it right
so the major issues are
sort of the relative effort of people
thinking about things going wrong each
particular thing and also relative to
like trying to make things go right
uh you know there's an upside and a
downside and we shouldn't all be looking
at the downside some two should be
looking for upsides and trying to work
those out too right
and then there's the timing question of
when is the right time to look at each
kind of problem so if we look at the
past we can certainly say you know if
you could have imagined in the year 1000
you know envisioning the Industrial
Revolution happening you could have
imagined tanks and airplanes and maybe
nuclear bombs or something
you could have imagined some of the
issues that might appear in the
industrial era
car accidents for example
um and then there'd be the question of
when is the right time to start working
on those
and you know I think it's pretty obvious
that for most of the things you could
have roughly envisioned far in the
future it was just too early to work on
them until you could have relatively
concrete versions
of the problems in front of you to work
with
you know you work on car accidents when
you had a roughly idea of how big a car
was
how fast it would be going how you know
how curvy would roads be you know how
much weather would matter you know you'd
want some rough idea of the basic
context
so that you could start to work on those
problems
we should we should say something about
the assumptions we're both working with
here so what we are interested in or
what I'm interested in at least is the
question of whether we could uh
in within the next say 30 or 50 years or
100 years get to a point where AI is
very very powerful maybe it is a general
so maybe we have artificial general
intelligence and maybe it is this type
of intelligence is misaligned with uh
human goals so that's what we are that's
this is why we're discussing uh progress
and and in your framing it is simply too
early to know what's interesting to work
on in in order to try to make sure that
that AI development will be safe for
Humanity so alignment you know would be
cashed out as there's people who have ai
systems and the AI systems are assisting
them in some ways and they are
supporting the AI systems with resources
and and development and then the AI
systems do things that on average
usually sort of help people that's why
they're funding them and making them and
then the AI systems get out of control
that is the purposes that they are
achieving and the effects they're having
deviate more and more from what the
people had in mind and what they
intended them to do and that out of
control Behavior becomes the problem so
that's I think we can agree that's the
scenario that you have in mind is that
a system you have gets out of control
that of course that's what a car
accident is in a literal sense the the
car you're driving gets out of control
and doesn't go where you intend and just
something specialist and do you use bash
into something else you lose control of
the situation you're usually in control
of I like where your car is where it's
going and the obstacles that it's going
to get around and the things that's not
going to hit it right and a lot of
system problems can be seen as
failures to control so like a coup a
coup is a failure to control a
government one of the things that can go
wrong with the government is it can have
a coup
and then the military take over and then
the people the current government loses
control and the citizens lose control
through the government they had and a
coup is a problem
and so when you design governments you
like to prevent coups
so a coup in a car accident are most
illustrations of particular kinds of
ways systems can get out of control
and now the question is if you're
worried about a future system getting
out of control
what do you need to know about it to be
how useful and in helping to prevent
those future control problems
and my argument would be there's
certainly a time when you're just pretty
much too early
when you really just don't have much I
need I had an idea what sort of concrete
forms these problems will take
and that therefore you really can't help
much
with that
um problem and then later on of course
there'll be a time when you you can help
a lot and maybe you waited too long
there might be a time when you were too
cautious in doing anything and you you
did know plenty enough to do something
and you just didn't do it yet right so
this is the issue when is a useful time
for thinking about a problem but one of
the parameters I would suggest is just
the concreteness of the versions of
these systems you have available to work
with relative to the problems you intend
they haven't right
if you think about car accidents you
should see actual things like cars and
Roads and see the actual kinds of
smashes they could have and damage that
will cause and the kind of paths that
would lead to that if you're looking at
coups of course you have to have an idea
of like what form of government you're
even in
what kind of military Technologies you
would have what would it would take to
form a coup that is what would you have
to take over is it the television
stations is the roads right I mean you
need some rough idea what it would be to
cause a coup so that you could try to
prevent coups but this is where it we
can return to the question of how we
measure proc as an AI because if we've
if we find a good measure a good a good
metric or a good proxy for for progress
and Ai and we find out that we have been
making very fast progress well then that
might mean that the systems we are
dealing with today the machine Learning
Systems we have today are closer to what
could be become an artificial uh
unofficial general intelligence in the
future and therefore that we today have
more of a concrete grasp on the systems
that could become dangerous in the
future do you agree on that framing
well there's a closer metric and there
are farther metrics so anytime we're
collecting metrics we should arrange
them on a scale of sort of how close
they are to the issue at mine versus how
indirect they're indirect metrics are
useful they can give an earlier warnings
but they are you know
they're usually a warning that a more
direct metric will then later
show itself and then that will be a
clearer measure of what you're
interested in so I might say well the
clearer metric is the actual lack of
control that is the that you would have
to you know the clearer problem is you
have an AI system doing something and
then the things that it is doing are
things that if if it did them badly or
out of control that would be a problem
right if if the thing you're having a
system doing isn't the sort of thing
that really could cause problems if done
badly
then you're not as close to the problem
itself as you would be as if so like a
self-driving car
is more in the auto accident world where
the self-driving car could cause an auto
accident
and therefore you're more worried about
it than a you know self toasting toaster
right
so you're you're saying that
um what is an indication that there
could be a problem in the future would
be to see examples of uh misaligned AI
systems actually happening so it's not
enough for us it's just misaligned but
misaligned it on in applications the
matter of applications where there's a
lot at stake and there's a lot that
could go wrong
all right all right but haven't we seen
a small scale examples of misaligned AI
systems here I'm thinking if you if you
give a an AI in a game uh some a goal to
achieve then it might achieve it in a
way that you did not intend for example
um if you want a a digital agent in a
game to run very far then this agent
might cheat by running in circles
because that's uh a fast way to kind of
game the the rules you've set up so we
have there's the small scale examples of
misaligned AI systems now we might be
able to extrapolate and think about how
these misaligned AI systems could could
work in in much larger settings so let's
take the analogy of computer security
which I think is an unusually close
analogy compared to other analogies we
could make
um we have a great many computer systems
in the world and a great many of them
are have vulnerable computer security
but the degree of effort we put into
security security in any one system is a
reflection of our concerns about that
application and what could go wrong
there so we put a lot more effort into
computer security in the military and in
banking
and didn't say medical instruments
uh because there's a lot more that can
go wrong there we put a lot less
computer security and to say social
media
or you know video games
as you're describing exactly because we
realize that if if something goes wrong
there's not that much to lose there so
because of that I think it would be
unfair to take an example of things
going wrong in video games and therefore
claiming we've got a big banking problem
or a big military problem
because we have been paying attention to
those differences in our security
similarly you might say you know you're
walking around and you don't have very
good Security on on the backpack you're
carrying
and that means like somebody's going to
break into your house and murder you
right and you might go well like I'm a j
I have a certain amount of security on
my backpack because of the kinds of
environments it's in this tends to be
good enough I I don't have a lock on my
backpack usually I could they sell back
back to lock I just never bothered to
put a lock on my backpack because it
doesn't look like that's a problem right
I do put a lock on my door
my lock on my door isn't well certainly
enough to prevent a military grade
professional from getting in
but I don't expect military grade
professionals to try to be breaking into
my house and murder me that's why I have
the sort of lock I have in my door right
so from this perspective this is why
we'd want to be seeing like problems
close to the actual problem like if
people were breaking into houses near me
and killing them that would call
attention that I might need a better
lock on my door right you would want to
see misaligned AI systems in
applications we really care about like a
finance or policing and so on maybe
um maybe a one problem with thinking
this way is that if we if we need that
kind of evidence before uh beginning to
invest in AI Safety Research don't we
risk being too complacent maybe maybe by
the time that kind of evidence surfaces
it's already very late
um in in the kind of progression towards
very dangerous systems also think about
the house lock thing right if nobody had
invented locks yet
then I might want somebody working on
the very idea of locks so that if I ever
wanted to lock on my door I could put a
lock on my door once locks are available
now it's a matter of which locks do I
put on right
so I think that's more the analogy
people might make is that there's a
whole new kind of technology for dealing
with problems that you might need to
invent
as opposed to you know how you're going
to particularly deal with a particular
problem but the problem with inventing a
whole new technologies for dealing with
problems is there are whole new
technologies for dealing with problems
and whole new systems you haven't seen
yet so we could say you know how do we
invent brakes on cars before you've even
seen cars how do we know brakes are the
right thing to do as opposed to Like Big
Bubbles stick out the front right okay
so like inside cars we have airbags and
on the outside we have brakes how do we
know what the right technology is until
we get close enough to actually have
access systems we could work on airbags
and and brakes just in general before we
have any idea what kind of systems we're
dealing with and of course you know
basically you know at the early
Industrial Revolution you just have a
list of all the different ways machines
are controlled right there's just a list
of you can have an off switch and you
can have a regulator and you can have a
shield and right there's just a list of
ways you could list as the kinds of
things you can do on machines to protect
from machines breaking but
could you do much more than that
is there an underlying assumption or a
set of assumptions here about how humans
generally solve problems so are you
thinking that for example humans are
better at adapting to a situation that
has already Arisen then we are at uh
preparing for a situation we haven't
seen before or something like that
um as we discussed in another podcast
uh there's this general question of
whether people plan too much or too
little and that seems relevant here
I would say I think we see a rough bias
toward too much planning at least in a
lot of socially shared contexts where
people get together so for example
consider The Insider review versus the
outside view discussion right the
observation is that in organizations at
least often people will take an inside
view with respect to something a famous
paper was about a curriculum design
using what they think they know about
the inside view make some plans about
how to do something and then
that just won't work very well compared
to taking an outside view of sort of a
track record of previous cases and just
taking a more an Adaptive approach of
you know
trying things and changing them and
trying things and changing them so trial
and error so I think that's not just
true in the inside view outside view
literature it's also true in say the you
know billion dollar projects in the
world if you look at sort of all
projects that cost more than a million
dollars in the world they typically go
very badly they are over budget they are
over time they don't work very well
and basically what people think they can
plan a billion dollar project they're
they tend to be wrong
it doesn't work and this is a also more
common observation about many kinds of
government programs they are playing
that they have too much planning
and even sort of government programs to
produce Innovation I learned this from
um infinite in all directions by Freeman
Dyson the book long ago where he
complained about most attempts to to
cause Innovation that was based on a lot
of planning that just didn't work very
well
Innovation plans that worked well were
both trial and error try something
change it try it again whereas when
people try to design say a huge you know
Fusion reactor from scratch and make a
project it took decades and didn't work
and
but of course there's also the question
of how many resources we are allocating
to trying to make AI systems safe
um we currently the world is allocating
a tiny tiny amount of resources to this
problem and do you think that kind of
marginally we should allocate less
because the because trying to plan now
simply too early but then I'm just
thinking if if we're allocating this
this tiny amount of resources
um this seems to be a good way to hatch
our bets even if it's in your way in
your view very unlikely that dangerous
AI systems will arrive soon so let's
talk about the kinds of resources you
might allocate them and how you might
allocate them
so
um one issue in the allocation is do you
spend the money an hour later so you
could allocate resources and put that in
a fund that then grew over time and then
you'd have guaranteed a big pile of
money later to spend when the time was
right when you might not be able to
convince people later to spend the money
then and there'd be all this money so
allocated resources doesn't mean
spending it now
it might mean just committing to have
the resources ready when the time is
right
um and then if we think about allocating
resources you know one thing we could do
is just cause people to spend time
writing white papers or something
but that's not the only resource we
allocate we also allocate the resource
of sort of concern and fear
and regulation that is you know these
sorts of concerns will often [ __ ] and
prevent various kinds of developments
make it not only you know financially
less attractive but have more regulation
that's in the way we will have more
distract people away because they'd be
ashamed to work on that sort of thing we
can sort of sap away the enthusiasm that
might be there behind things these are
other sorts of resources so you know the
best way to reassure me is to say well
we're just going to spend a small amount
of money and we're not going to get in
the way of those other things
because you know that might be the
bigger cost is that by talking so much
about AA safety and and making it sort
of so many people think it's the just
the biggest issue ever
that you sort of displace other images
of the future other concerns about the
future uh you take people who could
otherwise work on other interesting
things and you distract them to this and
then you sap away enthusiasm you create
more support for regulation uh you you
discourage organizations from pursuing
developments
those are some of the other major
resources we allocate so we should think
of it as maybe among the group of people
who are likely to work on a big scale
problems for the future uh
the problem of AI safety is overweight
so it's it's uh we we're allocating too
many resources to it within that group
that's a plausible concern all right all
right let's shift gears a little bit
here and talk about in general uh what
you believe about AI progress so
progress in in AI capability it just um
do you do you think that the the notion
of artificial general intelligence is
useful and and if you find it useful uh
do you have any any
um forecasts about when such a system or
collection of systems
agree on what history we see yeah okay
so you know computers got started you
know being substantially active in the
1950s
uh where there was precursors were
pretty small compared to that but
computers really started getting going
in the 1950s
and so it's been 70 years
since then
we've seen 70 years of computer history
in that 70 years we have seen relatively
steady Hardware progress
we've seen changes in Hardware
Technologies which dominate like
parallel Hardware is more important now
than it used to be
at a relatively steady rate at which
technologies that the the hardware is
improved and we understand that improved
Hardware has is a causal thing that can
unleash improve software
and in fact when we look at like
particular algorithms we see that
particular algorithms say inverting a
matrix or things like that they have
improved over time and the factor of
improvement in terms of efficiency is
actually similar to the hardware one
which is surprising because there's not
this big industry you have to create to
do the software improvements and so a
plausible explanation there that I think
you know I find plausible and other
people do too is that there are many
kinds of software approaches that you
can't really try until you have cheap
enough Hardware
and so that the software improvement
over time is that people have
you know with cheaper Hardware been able
to try a wider range of approaches
let's say so every algorithm has like a
fixed cost constant plus some you know
power some polynomial cost as a function
of scaling and we're able to explore
larger fixed costs
constants
as we you know have larger cheaper
computers and so that has produced
Improvement in algorithms but we also
see it's relatively steady actually
Improvement in algorithms over the 70
years in a wide range of areas
I think we can also you know look at
computer Innovations over the last 70
years in terms of their specificity or
generality
and we could also categorize them in
terms of their lumpiness or size so you
know there are areas where they're just
Lots especially in Hardware just lots of
little tiny improvements slowly over
time
that make it better and better
thousands really of little changes that
add up to making chips cheaper say and
even thousands of changes that add up to
making certain kinds of software more
effective
but once in a while there are bigger
lumps right so it's not an exact smooth
exponential curve it bounces around a
bit
but the bouncing is mild compared to the
overall
tread I think we'd agree like if say
Hardware even algorithms has like a
factor of two every two years well it's
not exactly a factor of every two years
sometimes a factor three sometimes it's
a factor 1.5 but it's roughly in that
range
that's roughly the the fluctuations in
in the breeds of progress over time
and we also see that most uh
improvements are relatively specific to
applications and areas that is there are
some relatively General improvements
like inverting a matrix
sorting a list right
but most in progress has just not been
in those General things most progress
has been in relatively
you know narrower
things that have a more limited range of
application
so that's the history I would paint so
far
and that history is roughly consistent
with the rest of technological
innovation that's not just the history
of computer science that's what
railroads look like and you know nuclear
reactors and everything else
it mostly has this character that
um you know there's hardware and
software advances
and they're somewhat similar and that
the rate of improvement is relatively
steady but it's somewhat lumpy but not
that Lumpy
and that most gains are specific to
particular Industries and there are
relatively few gains that are just you
know work across all possible Industries
and that's the history so far
and that's the history even though many
people were repeatedly forecasting a
deviation from that Trend that that's
this history of the every 30 years burst
of concern
for a while many people have thought
yeah we've seen the steady Trend so far
but we're going to see a breakout soon
we're going to see a way in which the
steady trend is going to undeviate soon
and then it's going to be a really big
change
um we could also talk even about if such
a big deviation were to occur what sort
of signatures might we expect to see but
if if we take just what you've been
talking about the trends the historical
Trends over the last 70 years what
happens if we extrapolate extrapolate
those Trends so so now we're not talking
about a prediction of a deviation which
suddenly hardware and software progress
is is much faster just the extrapolation
of those Trends where does that get us
so the straightforward prediction of
past trends
I think would be to expect that uh we
have similar rates of progress that
continue on for a long time
and now we we must need to project rates
of progress than distances
so so in this case the question is well
at the moment like
most income goes to pay human workers
and mostly to pay their minds uh that's
what most uh income in the world economy
is paid for human Minds doing stuff
right because human brains are pretty
good
and when we look over time we see that
as Automation and machines and computers
have improved we've seen a slow change
in that mix but a pretty slow change
so
um we might say uh even today most
income is going for human labors and
over the last say 50 or 70 years the
fraction of income paying for computers
and computer software is increased
definitely but it's still a pretty small
fraction
and if you project those Trends out it's
going to be a pretty long time until it
becomes large fraction of the economy
say compared to human labor so one's
Milestone we might be looking to is at
what point will the income going to
computers and software be comparable or
even larger than the income going to
human workers that would be a plausible
marking point of a important transition
certainly that's an important transition
for when humans should get insurance
about losing their wages
and then other sorts of developments
might be of concern at that point too
right so we might be trying to ask well
when would we reach that point if past
Trends were to continue
um and so for that I gotta say it you
know what you want to basically ask
people is okay
if you look at you know how far machines
would have to get in order to be able to
be able to do most everything humans do
if you look at like where they are now
and say maybe how far they've come in 20
years
what's the ratio of say how far they've
come in 20 years to how far they have to
go
and so if say that ratio is five well
you'd want to multiply 20 by 5 to get a
century is your prediction of how long
it would take to get to that point
so that would be one way of trying to
talk about how far do we have to go if
we continue at previous rates of
progress
so about about one century from now we
would expect to have
um machines receiving half of the wages
in the economy if it was a factor of
five now I didn't say it was a factor
five but that would be a you know a way
to try to do that estimate so in the
past when I try to do that estimate I
got you know predictions of several
centuries basically
uh that we were just a long way off and
we have a long way to go but still
several centuries is still short on a
cosmological Time certainly even on the
time of
recorded history uh is certainly
something to be looking forward to but
it's not around the corner is that your
best guess that it will take several
centuries to to to get to a point uh
where we have something like artificial
general intelligence or at least
something that receives half of the
wages in the economy right so this story
isn't about AGI in the sense that we
haven't even invoked the possibility of
AGI yet we've just been projecting
previous Trends which are mostly about
relatively specialized systems and
spread and you're asking when will those
specialized systems take away you know
take both wages
and there'd be some degree of generality
but that's ambiguous here so far right
this prediction has to be weighed
against other things that can happen
between now and then right so this is
the prediction if nothing else happens
I know he asks us what else can happen
right so one other thing could happen is
the topic of my book the age of M we
could achieve brain emulations
and then if we achieve writing relations
well before we had sort of computers
taking more than half of wages then we'd
have this transition where brain
emulations would take over the jobs that
humans were doing and then brain
emulations would continue the task of
automation
of improving automation they would they
would be writing the software and the
Machine Learning Systems et cetera
instead of the humans but they'd still
be going down that path but the rate
would change enormously I you know
estimate the brain emulation economy
instead of doubling every 15 years as
ours does my double every month or even
faster so you know it would be a radical
change but still they would be going
down that same path just faster
um another scenario of course could be
you know civilization collapse the the
power that's producing computer
Innovation would be undercut
and we would stop going down that path
that thing we could worry about but
these Trends have been quite
um persistent even they have depending
on how far you go back these Trends in
hardware and software progress have
survived uh at least one World War and
the Cold War and many highly disruptive
events um but of course we can imagine
complete collapse that would end these
trends
and then you know a third sort of
scenario is some sort of a deviation
from the Computer Trends we've talked
about
a deviation in rate or generality or
some combination of them
and this is the sign of scenario I've
most heard about over the last decades
and that's the really the kind of style
people have repeatedly been concerned
about every 30 years for a while right
is some
Innovation which is much more lumpy in
essence than the lumps we've seen so far
some way in which to be more general or
to open a Floodgate Of new innovation
that accumulates a lot faster
to produce much more rapid progress
uh so you know we could ask about How
likely it is that look we could ask
about well what signs would we expect to
see we could ask have we seen such signs
lately
um those would be you know the kinds of
questions we could ask about that
scenario because then we would have an
acceleration relative to what we see so
far
and what would those signs consist of
um what would we have to see in order to
believe that there's something going on
with the rate of change in AI progress
so we can go through a number of
different plausible signs we might see
so one is that if investors
expected this change that is they got
signs that this change was coming
they would change the relative prices of
some kinds of Investments
right if say the question is well
there's a new kind of computer
technology which has a new potential for
uh economic impact of
getting economic value in the economy
where do they think the that investment
will come from where what will be
embodied in who would be profiting from
those Investments so you might for
example think well this is computer
mediated so hey the price of computers
would go up all of a sudden there'd be
this huge possibility for using
computers more than you had in the past
and so and whatever kind of computer was
most suitable to be used in this new
technology well that price would go way
up
and you might think well whatever
software companies are likely to own the
new software that enables this new
technology their price would go way up
at least if it could own some fraction
of it
and um you know whatever
humans workers would be especially
valuable by employed by those companies
their wages would be expected to go up
people would be
expect trained
techniques
whatever Nations they're in companies
this those in our cities there's expect
to have more tax revenue they would have
more growth
and to what extent do you think we've
seen these Trends so for for every thing
you mentioned here we could go through
that list and say well we are seeing uh
lots of investments in artificial
intelligence machine learning
researchers are very highly paid uh
there's a lot of economic activity in
Silicon Valley which is kind of the
heart of of AI Innovation and so on so
uh what Google is is very very valuable
um and so on so where
to what extent uh are these signs
already kind of fulfilled so even a
small chance of such a thing could have
a substantial image and then technology
right a five percent chance say
in the next 20 years that Google would
be the pivotal company could
substantially affect the price of Google
uh so I think again since we've had this
history of these bursts of concern and
attention uh that's sort of the relevant
uh pattern to be comparing so I think
you might want to ask well do we see it
now different than we saw then
yeah that's a good framing is is the
level of innovative of investment and
concern uh higher than it was in another
AI cycle in the past
right so um
I think that um
we did see say in in say the 1930s
prior to that we saw this burst of
course in investment
uh based on technology more generally up
until the 29th crash
um we saw a burst of stock market
investment in the 60s
centered around more technology
companies
and
um
there was the big.com boom so that
comboom in the late 1990s
was explicitly said to be based on an
expectation that new technologies were
appearing that would enable a lot more
economic growth
um AI was the center of that but it was
within the mix and for example you know
the famous IBM
um
chess win was in 1997 you know two years
before the peak of the.com Boom so will
within that and we can look at sort of
how big a change the.com will move to
the relative value of say Tech versus
other sectors
and it was a substantial change
during the.com boom it looked like a
substantially large expectation that
there would be a change in the Economy
based on technology centered in
technology
that would make a big difference to
productivity and uh the value of
different kinds of firms
and of course they changed their mind in
99
and the crash
and I would say if we look at prices of
tech firms in the last 10 years
it has not been as dramatic a a change
as it was during the.com boot we have
not seen that level of expectation
uh of change it's it's it's not no
change but it's not that big
that's surprising to me so so we in the
previous AI Cycles we did not see we saw
higher levels of investment for example
into AI technology or uh expectations of
the valuation of Technology firms we saw
higher kind of activity in the past than
we than we are seeing now so let's be
clear about our sort of nested Circles
of a focus of attention here and and
let's think about what which which scale
the circle should matter right so at the
highest scale is just the economy as a
whole right how big is the economy how
fast is it growing and how much
investment does it have right
then there would be say more technology
more narrowly which could be say a
quarter of the economy side
you say uh how much do people expect
gains to come from technology and then
within technology we could talk about
computers
right because software and software and
then with computers we could talk about
AI more specifically and with AI we
could talk with an AI we could talk
about machine learning
and maybe even with machine learning we
could talk about deep learning
and now we've got these nested circles
and now we might ask
where in this set of nested circles do
we expect to see the signals and in what
order right
uh so when you get down to deep learning
you're looking at a pretty tiny fraction
of the world economy
uh but if you look at Tech you're
looking at a much bigger fraction and
even computers is a substantial fraction
so you know where do you expect to see
the change so I think if you're
expecting to see a an economy-wide
impact
that will should be reflected on the
quantum I parameters or even tech-wide
parameters
or even computer-wide parameters uh but
like lately the AI boom hasn't really
done changed the computer industry that
value
munch
and or even Tech so much it's been part
of a tech movement it's less clear that
it's AI That's the main driver of the
price of Google or Apple or something it
does that doesn't seem plausible so
maybe an assumption we're working with
here is that the market is good at
pricing it's got a prediction predicting
which technologies will be valuable in
the future yeah I I agree that this this
kind of thing
being betting against the market it
definitely puts pressure on people who
are predicting that we will see rapid AI
progress in the next say 30 years or so
but I mean that we have had instances
where the market has has uh
bet on the wrong things or not foreseen
some some change so so here's another
metric right so I'll give two more
metrics here we could talk about
one metric would be because I did this
actually a statistical analysis I looked
at the United States economy from 1999
to 2019
at 900 different kinds of jobs and for
each kind of job in each year how
automated was that job
and so I could look at Trends in
Automation in the US economy over 20
years including a period where many
people said that we're about to have an
enormous amount of change in automation
due to AI
and so in this data set I could look at
when jobs got more or less automated did
that change the number of workers doing
that job or the wages for that job and I
could ask what predicts which jobs are
how automated that are what are the
usual determinants of whether a job is
automated which kind of job features
and for example we could ask in
particular whether the things that
predicted a job being automated had
changed in those 20 years
that is if there was a new kind of
automation showing up that was having an
important impact in the economy we might
expect not just maybe an acceleration in
the rate of innovation the rate of
automation we might expect a change in
which kinds of jobs are being automated
and maybe even a change in whether the
automation is causing a change in the
number of workers of the wages and the
answer of this analysis was there was no
change over this 20 years in the things
that predicted which jobs are automated
there was no change in the rate of
automation chain increase there was no
correlation between jobs being more or
less automated and having higher or
lower wages or higher and lower numbers
of workers
so basically no sign of any automation
Revolution from 1999 to 2019 in the
United States economy overall
a lot to say it couldn't happen in the
future but it hadn't happened yet
um so the the last metric
to use I think which would be sort of
getting the closest to the phenomena is
that you know we have excited people
excited in the last few years with
things like gpt3 and Dolly right
generators of language and generations
of images
and the most direct question to ask
about those is
are they getting commercial attraction
are there customers who want to pay to
use them to get value from customers
that's the most straightforward question
would be to ask about that I mean again
I don't think that's necessarily an
indication of a vast change in AI but
it's if you were saying is there a new
technology that's appearing right now
that's about to cause a big change that
plausibly would be the thing you
somebody would be pointing to and then
the most straightforward indication that
would be about to be causing a big
change is that it was getting some
traction with customers people were
paying for it
they were doing stuff with it right
and so for example I've made a bet with
my colleague Alex tabarak about the
amount of revenue from gpt3 sort of
products that will appear in the next 10
years I guess
and I bet it was less than a billion and
he bet it was more than a billion and so
I think there's a market on that on
metaculous and it says about 50 50. so
people don't think I'm obviously wrong
that they'll be less than a billion
dollars in revenue from the latest new
thing and a billion dollars is Tiny in
the world economy right you gotta say If
you think maybe there'll be a billion
dollars maybe not you're not talking
about a revolution in the world economy
that's a great way to end it there Robin
um thank you for talking with me
thank you for talking